[Music]
while broadway's getting ready to
officially reopen in september
london's theater district is already
coming back to life so in a normal year
more than
15 million people visit theaters in
london's west end
about 1 million more than broadway but
the pandemic shut down dozens of venues
only a few of the smaller shows could
afford to reopen with coveted
restrictions
and as roxanna seberry shows us the
leading ladies of the new musical
six are among those who are back and
they are having a
royally good time
[Music]
after five centuries of silence
five months of lockdown these queens are
singing their side
of british history
[Music]
[Applause]
the six ill-fated wives of henry viii
recently stormed back on stage
competing for the title of the king's
most unfortunate
wife
[Music]
ex-wife and then i was like okay what's
like a famous subject matter from
history with all women
toby marlowe and lucy moss dreamed up
the pop musical 6 as students at
cambridge university
and why does henry not appear at all
we've heard what he's had to say for the
last 500 years so
it's time for them to take the
microphone
six left from college campus to london's
west end
and almost broadway in under three years
so we've got deforest yeah beheaded
died one is missing
we met a few of the west end queens
whose characters were inspired by pop
stars like beyonce and nicki minaj
whether you're someone that just loves
history british history whether you're
someone that just
loves you know empowerment and it ticks
every box
and women in general as well yeah boom
like all movies
all shapes all sciences different
backgrounds different skin colors and
it's just sensational so just
celebrating
women
[Applause]
those themes and catchy songs quickly
created a queendom of fans
across the world but just hours before
its broadway debut last year in march
the covet 19 pandemic forced new york's
theaters to shut
lucy you were going to be the youngest
woman to direct
a musical on broadway i still like to
claim that that crown for myself
because we had a month of previews back
in london
a lockdown shut down the west end too
six reopened in december
only to close again just one week later
it's what we do it's what we love to do
so to have that taken away from us
was hard when the stages went dark an
estimated 40 percent of theater workers
lost their jobs with theaters like this
sitting
empty for months this billion dollar
industry has been devastated
six is just one of a few shows that's
been able to raise its curtain again
but in a new way audience members have
to wear masks
get temperature checks and scan in with
the track and trace app
measures that didn't deter these fans
how excited are you guys i'm so ecstatic
i'm going i'm
i'm flying on that inside plexiglas
separates the band members from the cast
and the seats can only be
half full does any of that affect the
energy of your production
i i don't think it has i think people
are just
so happy to be in a theater watching
live
theater but with coronavirus cases
rising again
in england these performers hope the
show goes on here
and in new york are there things
broadway can learn
from what you're experiencing on the
west end i just hope that they can open
sooner and be like us and be able to
just do what we love and bring the bring
the happiness back
and we could all use an encore
for cbs this morning roxanna saberi
london
boy we sure could can't wait for
broadway to come back september 17th 6th
opens i'm running judged by the fan
reactions in the uk it's going to be a
big deal
you're watching cbs this morning we'll
be right back